Yanis oui je vais te proposer deux
personnes qui vont défiler en talon
d'accord tu vas me dire franchement ce
que tu en penses ok que c'est très
difficile vous êtes peu à le faire toi
tu le fais extrêmement bien vous pourrez
rappeler aussi que tu as une base de
danse voilà tu as une école à Paris non
c'est pas mon écran quoi
je voudrais ouvrir une école dedans tu
vas venir maintenant
on en parle un petit peu parce qu'il
faut que je prenne un petit pourcentage
mais pour l'instant les talons sont là
et ont été choisis totalement au hasard
pour leur grâce et leur distinction
Maxime gueny et Jean-Michel maire
oh là là vous y allez les gars n'oubliez
pas un mannequin c'est quelqu'un de beau
et quelqu'un de beau emmerde les moches
donc tu ne souris pas
ok
[Applaudissements]
on ne sourit pas
alors là déjà rien que le plateau est
très énorme
voilà voilà et vous savez vous pouvez
les garder
[Rires]
vous pourrez les garder pour chez vous
c'est un beau cadeau de la maison très
serré c'est du 44 vous m'avez dit vous
savez quoi
alors on va y aller attends ne vous
cassez rien parce que Jean-Mi il a quand
même alors toi tu vas y aller j'ai un
micro alors tu viens là alors Yanis
est-ce que tu peux juste me faire à pied
une démonstration
tu me montres comment on fait un défilé
le sourire le machin tu reviens quand
même
s'il te plaît musique let's go
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'est bon ça
si
OK
[Applaudissements]
alors tu réserves ta note tu réserves ta
note on peut
être surpris
je te le dis ça fait un petit moment que
tu fais plus de télé je sais c'est ton
moment c'était Jo d'accord musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ton avis sur chacun et est-ce que ce
genre de chute est déjà arrivé à moi non
mais c'est déjà arrivé
du coup je pense que le gagnant
[Rires]
non mais c'est pas mais pourtant tu es
parti avec tellement de motivation
tu sais vous savez ce que c'est la
conclusion il faut rester sec en talon
s'il vous plaît on écoute Yanis
je peux je peux t'appeler Jean-Louis et
ben non Jean-Mi c'est bien faut juste
rendre les jambes faut tendre un petit
peu plus les gens
mais je t'ai surtout vu courir pour
vivre
il faut pas regarder par terre aussi
mais vous savez ce que c'est la
conclusion le jeune court vite le vieux
connait le chemin
[Applaudissements]